Russia has agreed to extend the Ukraine
grain export deal following talks with
the UN but only for 60 days half the
term of the previous agreement the grain
export pact has helped to ease the
global food crisis triggered by Russia's
invasion of Ukraine last year more than
24 million tons of grain have been
exported under the deal let's go live
now to Al jazeera's Stephanie Decker
who's following developments for us in
Ukraine's Capital Kiev Steph why is
Moscow only willing to extend this deal
for a further 60 days and what's been
the reaction to that they're in Kiev
Alaska Moscow has been complaining that
the part of the deal that affects it is
not being upheld also concerning its
exports saying that sanctions apply to
things like not directly to its industry
but things like payments insurance and
Logistics are affecting its exports
which is why it's been dragging its feet
on this but now after those talks
suggesting that it will extend the deal
for half of what it is set to do it's
supposed to be extended under the
agreement for 120 days it's now saying
it'll agree to do so for 60. the
reaction from here is that this is
something that means that the deal may
need to be renegotiated because Russia
is not adhering to its part now this is
a lot of back and forth uh posturing
politically but I think it looks like
certainly at the moment if you speak to
analysts that it looks like this deal
will be extended the deadline is on
Saturday March 18th it's a deal that is
vital to when it comes to calming Global
food prices in particular which is why
it was really pushed to be you know
implemented Ukraine is one of the
world's biggest supplier of wheat 49 of
sunflower oil wheat and Grains Going
Global really also supplying things like
the world food program which then
filters that through to places like
Yemen and Somalia and South Sudan so it
gives you an indication of just how
Global the reach of this deal is when it
was implemented uh last year the exports
almost fell to pre-war level so it does
give the indication of just how
successful it has been of course it does
give Russia leverage over Ukraine it
actually we heard from the Ukrainian
president zelenski in his nightly
addresses yesterday actually but
specifically talking about it and also
about Farmers a lot of the fields here
remain heavily mined in areas that
Russia did occupy and then withdrew from
so this is also something that's being
looked at to try and step up those
demining efforts when it comes to the
farming season now with sowing season
when it comes to next year's crop so all
of that wrapped in it does look like the
deal will be extended on Saturday it may
just be for 60 days but it looks like it
will happen
how's your Stephanie Decker live in Kiev
Steph many thanks